eigentlich müssen wir hierhin leute
macht der fakten eigene bruder die
freundin ausspannen ist so unmöglich
ein name der jedem zuschauer bekannt ist
das was wird sich wirklich dem
dauergrinsen und den würden und diese
youtube außer dem vorfall im jahr aber
noch weitere den aufseher gewissen das
werde ich heute ermitteln mein name
special agent jack link s ist an der
stelle als ermittler meine pflicht alle
logen paul-fans hatte meinen zuschauern
darauf hinzuweisen dass dieses video
selbstverständlich mit humor zu nehmen
ist und dass alles was ihr in den
kommentaren sagen gegen sie verwendet
werden kann man natürlich wenn wir
darüber hinaus unsere ergebnisse wieder
auf der wissenschaftlichen hague level
skala dokumentieren wer allerdings zu
ernst und schreibt lahm ist mein idol du
bist ok fangen ja nur comics im
rostocker fans we zu der erste teil der
berichterstattung sind scheinbar tweets
schreibt hier auch theologen paul
wassermelonen machen euren penisgröße
schwarze männer soja erhöht das östrogen
level in eurem körper verringerte auf
jenes größe asiaten warum twittert man
so was ich würde ich sagen ist das
kontext gerissen aber warum warum warum
schreibt ich verstehe diese vorschriften
sind unterschiedlich was meine leute
jetzt nicht mehr lustig sondern ist
einfach nur rassistisch so also
wassermelone und schwarze und soja und
asiaten und ich verstehe es nicht dass
er kein pluspunkt aber ich würde das
gerne aber noch nicht an dann habt ihr
noch mal 2012 usain ich glaube es geht
um usain bolt user in looks like oder
flaschen auf das ist afrika geboren und
witz ich verstehe wirklich nicht warum
schreibt man solchen tweets ist nicht
mal witzig ist nicht lustig oder so es
ist einfach nur rassistischen
nach dem ersten leute aber das muss
jetzt leider die erste markierung sein
ich bleib objektiv ich bleibe attraktiv
aber du musst auf jeden fall jetzt hier
auch der held davis garantieren kommt
sozusagen sagen wir hier unten einer von
euch schreibt das so wie es aussieht
okay dann haben jetzt natürlich die
japanreise alles wohl dokumentiert
natürlich auch mit der leiche gefilmt
wurde sicherlich sein größtes vergehen
aber nicht sein einziges wirklich sagen
okay also ich bin wirklich fair ich
versuche wirklich fair und objektiv zu
bleiben
dieses ganze theater von wegen ja in
japan respekt und respekt
das hat mich nicht dass erhöhte ich mein
händler es bleibt genau gleich
okay das ist wirklich das ist einfach
schon asozial so also meinetwegen so ein
bisschen der rumschreit und so theater
machen und sich so anziehen meinetwegen
aber das sind erwachsene menschen die
einfach nur ihren den job mache auf der
straße rumlaufen aber dürfte auch keine
party pur gewählte auf mensch japaner
sind keine pokemon japaner sind auch
homo sapiens sapiens dass die gleiche
hast du wie du bist du nicht diese
kleinen monster die man den weißbuch
empfängt
jannis couvet mein gott zu sich zu allen
leuten muss auch noch eine polizistin
abwerfen
warum ist eigentlich im gefängnis
gelandet
man weiß es nicht also wie gesagt meint
legen sodass rumschreit ist okay aber
stellt euch vor ihr werten japaner
kennen wo das fahrrad tokio und lobt
dafür über die straße gemacht hat was
sie gerade so macht man kommt einfach so
ein amerikaner und wirft ein scheiß poke
weil auf euch welchen film berichtet
jetzt das geht auf gar keinen fall klar
diese story wer kennt es auch leute
locken paul carla bleiben da hat er so
getan als wäre farben wenn man so eine
brille aufsetzen hat dann so getan als
würde zum ersten mal in seinem leben
farben sehen
das ist so schlecht schauspieler mein
papagei
die hat doch nur eine farbe wurde in der
papagei hat viel fahren
wirklich ich wusste gar hinter sich
farblich bin trotz der vater dass man
diese szene leute da hat er sich diese
brille aufzusetzen so richtig
geschauspielert und das video hat so
viele klicks gemacht bei dem ok er ist
natürlich das durfte natürlich nicht
fehlen das video über die leiche in
japan bisher schon breitgetreten bei uns
wieder auch keinen bock mehr zu
verlieren eigentlich ist das schon so
indem drin wenn wir überleben wollen
nachdem geht man auch automatisch
darüber nach dass er irgendwie so die
leiche gefilmt hat aber trotzdem einfach
ich muss leute ich muss will ich aber
ich muss auch hier noch bis ins leben
hoch verliert es ist einfach immer noch
nicht okay okay das ist jetzt die sache
besser weile haben fast schon gute name
war vorher mit jack bauer so wissen
zusammenhang gab zu beziehungsstress
jack holzer gegangen und dann flogen
paul mit ihr was gestartet und ist schon
krass also der eigene bruder der einem
positiv freundin oder eine freundin aus
spannenden menschen nicht gesehen
ziemlich abstoßend
sie hat mit seinem bruder gevögelt und
deswegen hat er sie rausgeschmissen
stellt euch das mal vorstellen bevor
eure eigene bruder und da ich weiß ich
kann man ja eigentlich nicht aber wir
machen jetzt einen anstrich in jedem
fall dass es war es was jack polder
gesagt hat müssen wir einfach hier
fucking eigentlich müssen wir hier leute
dem eigenen bruder die zeitspanne ist so
unmöglich und die scala belegte
ich hasse nach diesem video auf jeden
fall logan paul noch mehr als vorher
ich wusste schon dass der rücksichtslos
ist dass wir diese sache gemacht hat in
japan aber dass elisabeth richtigkeit
wenn das war es meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren dank bist du schon zu
weit
wir sehen uns bei der nächsten
beweisaufnahme